i think a lot of people are looking at
what's happening to these democrat-run
cities and they're disgusting
they see what's going on and they can't
believe this is taking place in our
country
i can't believe it either one of the
reasons i'm
making the trip today and going to
wisconsin as we've had such a big
success
in shutting down what would be right now
a city that would have been kenosha
a city that would have been burnt to the
ground by now
and we're going to really uh say hello
to law enforcement and the national
guard
and it all stopped immediately upon the
national guard's arrival
so you know be easy to stop i saw last
night where
these radical anarchists were trying to
get into the mayor's house and lots of
bad things were happening to this poor
foolish
very stupid mayor i mean how he could be
mayor i have no idea but all he has to
do is call and within 10 minutes
their problem will be over as you know
they have to call us
they have to call and request help all
he has to do is call
and the problem will end they had
tremendous numbers of people
really harassing him horribly and i
guess trying to break into his house
and he still sticks up with him because
he's a fool only a fool would stick up
for him like that
these are anarchists these are agitators
they're rioters they're looters they're
bad people
they're burning down portland and you
take a look at that you take a look at
the scenes last night
and then the fake news media will say
that they're friendly protesters
because you people i'll tell you if we
only had an honest press in this country
would be
much more advanced but we have a very
dishonest press
yes can you speak at all you've spoken a
lot about the anarchy that you're
referring to
what about racial divisions would you
like to bridge some of those gaps
and do you yeah anything that you're
saying is helping with that
i think it's helping because i'm about
law and order and if you look at
the black community they want the police
to help them
stop crime the hispanic community they
want police
82 percent 84 numbers that you haven't
even seen
they don't want crime they don't want to
be mugged
they don't want to have any problems and
it's just a shame
and as far as the previous
administration take a look at baltimore
what happened
was it freddie gray take a look at
baltimore
take a look at st louis take a look at
ferguson take a look at what happened
what they had was
put what we're doing and put them to
shame to put it to shame take a look at
those places
and you always had portland portland's
been like this i read an article today
for 50 years this has been going on
i'd like to stop it and we can stop it
quickly
all they have to do is say okay
president now we're ready
now we're ready when i watched that
scene last night with all of those
really horrible people outside of the
mayor's house
i also saw the way they shot the young
gentleman in the street he was targeted
they targeted him they shot him in the
street and then they were so happy and
he died
you don't mention that you mentioned
somebody sprayed painted somebody
from the other side they shot a man in
the street they executed a man in the
street
a religious man in the street
and you don't mention it's not even a
story you talk about other things
the press should be ashamed of
themselves i think the press is actually
the media
is what's fueling this more so than even
by
because biden doesn't know he's alive
the press is really fueling this
and they're fueling it horribly and
you're doing a great disservice to your
country
okay any other questions
no i may i'm also going to be speaking
with a pastor
who was talking to as per your question
previously very
well involved and respected man i look
forward to that
i spoke to him yesterday by the way
pastor of the family as you know and i
spoke to him yesterday i had a great
conversation i think he's going to be
there
but i'm speaking really today i'm there
for law enforcement
and for the national guard because
they've done a great job in kenosha
they put out the flame immediately as
soon as they came in
boom the flame was gone now maybe it'll
start up again
in which case they'll put it out very
powerfully
well i told them that they have till
september 15 to make a deal after that
we close it up
in this country and i said that the
united states has to be compensated well
compensated because
we are the ones that are making it
possible
and so we should be compensated so the
treasury has to be well compensated
mr president do you have an update on
airlines what your administration wants
to do to help airlines well we'll be
helping the airlines yeah we'll be
helping you and you have to help you
it's tough business always is
airlines are a tough business in good
times and
uh we're about ready to get back to good
times
if you look at the numbers this morning
some of the numbers coming out are
incredible
we have now the all-time highest stock
market
if you take the average we're at a
number that nobody would even believe
we're doing well we have
tremendous uh i tell you we have
tremendous
what would you say is the best word the
enthusiasm for the country the
enthusiasm for the comeback
the v you look at the v now i think it's
a super v
and morgan stanley of course which is
one of the most respected on wall street
would you say they just made a big
prediction you know what the prediction
was right
that president trump is going to remain
president so we'll have to see
we'll have to see but i don't i cannot
imagine
anything else because if somebody else
got in namely my opponent
your stock markets instead of being
records right now
they will crash your 401ks will be down
to nothing
your stocks will be down to nothing and
we will have a depression
like you've never seen before we're
going to have an incredible economy
next year is going to be one of the best
years that we've ever had
and everybody's getting a big tax cut
thank you very much
yeah we're working with the drug
companies on substantially
lowering drug prices i've put out a
favored nations clause i've signed it
that means we get the lowest prices
anywhere in the world we match whoever
gets the lowest
and the drug companies have a real
problem with that so they're coming in
to see me
and we expect to get a very substantial
uh
price reduction in prescription drugs
which has never been done before
they're coming yeah they're coming